so i would like to start
by telling you about one of my greatest
friends oklahoma madrid
oklahoma lived on my street and looked
after me like a big brother
if i liked a boy i would ask the
columbus opinion
oklahoma died in the notorious solicito
plane crash
in nigeria in december of 2005
almost exactly seven years ago oklahoma
was the person i could argue with
laugh with and truly talk to
he was also the first person to call me
a feminist
i was about 14 we were in his house
arguing
both of us bristling with half-baked
knowledge from books that we had read
i don't remember what this particular
argument was about
but i remember that as i argued and
argued oklahoma looked at me and said
you know you're a feminist it was not a
compliment
i could tell from his tone the symptom
that you would use to say something like
you're a supporter of terrorism
i did not know exactly what this word
feminist meant
and i did not want a columnar to know
that i did not know
so i brushed it aside and i continued to
argue and the first thing i planned to
do when i got home was to look up the
word feminist in the dictionary
now fast forward to some years later
i wrote a novel about a man who among
other things beats his wife and whose
story doesn't end very well
while i was promoting the novel in
nigeria a journalist
a nice well-meaning man told me he
wanted to advise me
and for the nigerians here i'm sure
we're all familiar with
how quick how quick our people are to
give unsolicited advice
he told me that people were saying that
my novel was feminist
and his advice to me and he was shaking
his head sadly as he spoke
was that i should never call myself a
feminist because feminists are women who
are unhappy because they cannot find
husbands
so i decided to call myself a happy
feminist
then an academic a nigerian woman told
me that feminism was not our culture
that feminism was an african
and that i was calling myself a feminist
because i had been corrupted by western
books
which amused me because a lot of my
early reading was decidedly unfeminist i
think i must have read every single
milson boone romance published before i
was 16.
and each time i tried to read those
books called the feminist classics i get
bored
and i really struggle to finish them but
anyway since feminism was on african
i decided i would now call myself a
happy african feminist
at some point i was a happy african
feminist who does not hate men
and who likes lip gloss and who wears
high heels for herself but not for men
of course a lot of this was tongue in
cheek but that word feminist is so heavy
with baggage
negative baggage you hate men you hate
bras you hate african culture that sort
of thing
now here's a story from my childhood
when i was in primary school
my teacher said at the beginning of term
that she would give the class a test
and whoever got the highest call would
be the class monitor now class monitor
was a big
deal if you're a class monitor you got
to write down the names of noisemakers
which was heavy enough power on its own
but my teacher would also give you a
cane
to hold in your hand while you walked
around and patrolled the class for
noisemakers
now of course you were not actually
allowed to use the cane
but it was an exciting prospect for the
nine-year-old me
i very much wanted to be the class
monitor and i got the highest score on
the test
then to my surprise my teacher said that
the monitor had to be a boy
she had forgotten to make that clear
earlier because she assumed it was
obvious
a boy had the second highest score on
the test and he
would be monitored now what was even
more interesting about this is that
the boy was a sweet gentle soul who had
no interest in patrolling the class with
a cane
while i was full of ambition to do so
but i was female and he was male and so
he became the class monitor
and i've never forgotten that incident i
i often make the mistake of thinking
that something that is obvious to me is
just as obvious to everyone else now
take my dear friend louie
for example louie is a brilliant
progressive man and we would have
conversations and he would tell me
i don't know what you mean by things
being different or harder for women
maybe in the past but not now and i
didn't understand how louis could not
see what seemed so self-evident
then one evening in lagos louis and i
went out with friends
and for people here who are familiar
with lagos there's that wonderful lagos
fixture
the sprinkling of energetic men who hang
around outside
establishments and very dramatically
help you pack your car
i was impressed with the particular
theatrics
of the man who found us a parking spot
that evening
and so as we were leaving i decided to
give him a tip
i opened my bag put my hand inside my
bag brought out my money that i had
earned from doing my work
and i gave it to the man and he
this man who was very grateful and very
happy took the money from me
looked across at louie and said thank
you sir
louis louie looked at me surprised
and asked why is he thanking me i didn't
give him the money
then i saw realization dawn on louie's
face
the man believed that whatever money i
had had ultimately came
had ultimately come from louis because
louie is a man
now men and women are different we have
different hormones we have different
sexual organs we have different
biological abilities
women can have babies men can't
at least not yet men have testosterone
and are in general
physically stronger than women there's
slightly more women
than men in the world about 52 percent
of the world's population is female
but most of the positions of power and
prestige are occupied by men
the late kenyan nobel peace laureate
juan gary mathai
put it simply and well when she said the
higher you go
the fewer women they are
in the recent u.s elections we kept
hearing of the lilly ledbetter law
and if we go beyond the nicely
alliterative name of that law
it was really about a man and a woman
doing the same job being equally
qualified
and the man being paid more because he's
a man
so in a literal way men rule the world
and this made sense a thousand years ago
because human beings lived then in a
world in which physical strength was the
most important attribute for survival
the physically stronger person was more
likely to lead
and men in general are physically
stronger of course there are many
exceptions
but today we live in a vastly different
world
the person more likely to lead is not
the physically stronger person
it is the more creative person the more
intelligent person the more
innovative person and there are no
hormones
for those attributes a man is as likely
as a woman to be intelligent to be
creative to be innovative
we have evolved but it seems to me that
our ideas of gender have not evolved
some weeks ago i walked into the lobby
of one of the best nigerian hotels
i thought about naming the hotel but i
thought i probably shouldn't and a guard
at the entrance stopped me and
asked me annoying questions because the
automatic assumption is that a nigerian
female walking into a hotel alone is a
sex worker
and by the way why do these hotels focus
on the ostensible supply rather than the
demand
for sex workers in lagos i cannot
go alone into many reputable bars and
clubs
they just don't let you in if you're a
woman alone you have to be accompanied
by a man
each time i walk into a nigerian
restaurant with a man the waiter greets
the man and ignores me
the waiters are products are there some
women who are like yes
the waiters are products of a society
that has taught them
that men are more important than women
and i know the waiters don't intend any
harm
but it is one thing to know
intellectually and quite another to feel
it
emotionally each time they ignore me i
feel invisible
i feel upset i want to tell them that i
am just
as human as the man that i am just as
worthy
of acknowledgement these are little
things but sometimes it's the little
things that sting the most
now not long ago i wrote an article
about what it means
to be young and female in lagos and an
acquaintance told me
it was so angry of course it was angry
i am angry gender as it functions today
is a grieving justice we should all be
angry
anger has a long history of bringing
about positive change
but in addition to being angry i'm also
hopeful
because i believe deeply in the ability
of human beings to make and remake
themselves for the better
gender matters everywhere in the world
but i want to focus on nigeria
and on africa in general because it is
where i know and because it is where my
heart is
and i would like today to ask that we
begin to dream about and plan for
a different world a fairer world
a world of happier men and happier women
who are truer to themselves
and this is how to start we must raise
our daughters differently
we must also raise our sons differently
we do a great disservice to boys and how
we raise them
we stifle the humanity of boys we define
masculinity in a very narrow way
masculinity becomes this hard small cage
and we put boys inside the cage we teach
boys to be afraid of fear
we teach boys to be afraid of weakness
of vulnerability
we teach them to mask their true selves
because they have to be
in nigeria speak hard man
in secondary school a boy and a girl
both of them teenagers
both of them with the same amount of
pocket money would go out and that the
boy would be expected
always to pay to prove his masculinity
and yet we wonder why boys are more
likely to steal money from their parents
what if both boys and girls were raised
not to link masculinity with money what
if the attitude was not
the boy has to pay but rather whoever
has more should pay
now of course because of the historical
advantage it is mostly men who will have
more today
but if we start raising children
differently then in 50 years in 100
years
boys will no longer have the pressure of
having to prove this masculinity
but by far the worst thing we do to
males
by making them feel that they have to be
hard is that we leave them with
very fragile egos the more
hard man a man feels compelled to be
the weaker his ego is
and then we do a much greater disservice
to girls because we raise them to cater
to the fragile egos of men
we teach girls to shrink themselves to
make themselves smaller
we say to girls you can have ambition
but not too much you should aim to be
successful but not too successful
otherwise you will threaten
the man if you are the breadwinner in
your relationship with a man
you have to pretend that you're not
especially in public
otherwise you will emasculate him
but what if we question the premise
itself why should a woman's success
be a threat to a man what if we decide
to simply dispose of that word and i
don't think there's an english word i
dislike
more than emasculation
a nigerian acquaintance once asked me if
i was worried that
men would be intimidated by me i was not
worried at all
in fact it had not occurred to me to be
worried because a man who will be
intimidated by me
is exactly the kind of man i would have
no interest in
[Music]
but still i was i was really struck by
this
because i am female i'm expected to
aspire to marriage i'm expected to make
my life choices always keeping in mind
that marriage is the most important a
marriage
can be a good thing it can be a source
of joy and love and
mutual support but why do we teach girls
to aspire to marriage and we don't teach
boys the same
i know a woman who decided to sell her
house because she didn't want to
intimidate a man who might marry her
i know an unmarried woman in nigeria who
when she goes to conferences
wears a wedding ring because according
to her she wants the other participants
in the conference to
give her respect i know young women who
are under so much pressure from family
from friends even from work
to get married and they're pushed to
make terrible choices
a woman at a certain age who is
unmarried our society teaches how to see
it as a deep
personal failure and a man at a certain
age who's unmarried
we just think he hasn't come around to
making his pick
it's easy for us to say oh but women can
just say no to all of this
but the reality is more difficult and
more complex
we're all social beings we internalize
ideas from our socialization
even the language we use in talking
about marriage and relationships
illustrates this the language of
marriage is often a language of
ownership rather than a language of
partnership
we use the word respect to mean
something a woman shows a man
but often not something a man shows a
woman
both men and women in nigeria will say
and this is an expression i'm very
amused by
i did it for peace in my marriage
now when men say it it is usually about
something that they should not be doing
anyway
sometimes sometimes they say to their
friend it's something to say to their
friends in a kind of fondly exasperated
way
you know something that ultimately
proves how masculine they are how
needed how loved oh my wife said i can't
go to the club every night so for peace
in my marriage i do it only on weekends
now when a woman says i did it for peace
in my marriage
she's usually talking about having
giving up a job
a dream a career
we teach females that in relationships
compromise
is what women do we raise girls to see
each other as competitors
not for jobs or accomplishments which i
think can be a good thing
but for the attention of we teach girls
that they cannot be sexual beings
in the way that boys are if we have sons
we don't mind knowing about our son's
girlfriends
but our daughter's boyfriend's god
forbid
but of course when the time is right we
expect those girls to bring back the
perfect man to be their husband
we police girls we praise girls for
virginity
but we don't praise boys for virginity
and it's always made me wonder how
exactly this is supposed to work out
because
[Applause]
i mean the loss of virginity is usually
a process that involves
recently a young woman was gang-raped in
the university in nigeria
i think some of us know about that and
the response of many young nigerians
both male and female was something along
the lines of this
yes rape is wrong but what does a girl
do in a room in doing in a room with
four boys
now if we can forget the horrible
inhumanity of that response
these nigerians have been raised to
think of women as inherently guilty
and they've been raised to expect so
little of men
that the idea of men as savage beings
without any control is somehow
acceptable
we teach girls shame close your legs
cover
yourself we make them feel as though by
being born female they're already guilty
of something
and so girls grow up to be women who
cannot say they have desire
they grow up to be women who silence
themselves
they grow up to be women who cannot say
what they truly think
and they grow up and this is the worst
thing we do to girls
they grow up to be women who have turned
pretense into an art form
i know i know a woman who hates domestic
walk
she just hates it but she pretends that
she likes it
because she's been taught that to be
good wife material
she has to be to use that nigerian ward
very
homely and then she got married
and after a while her husband's family
began to complain that she had changed
actually she had not changed she just
got tired of pretending
the problem the problem with gender
is that it prescribes how we should be
rather than recognizing how we are
now imagine how much happier we would be
how much
freer to be our true individual selves
if we didn't have the weight of gender
expectations
boys and girls are undeniably different
biologically but socialization
exaggerates the differences
and then it becomes a self-fulfilling
process now take cooking
for example today women in general are
more likely to do the housework than men
the cooking and cleaning
but why is that is it because women are
born with a cooking gene
or because over years they have been
socialized to see cooking as their role
actually i was going to say that maybe
women are born with a cooking gene
until i remember that the majority of
the famous cooks in the world
who we give the fancy title of chefs are
men
i used to look at my grandmother who was
a brilliant brilliant woman
and wonder how she would have been if
she had the same opportunities as
men when she was growing up now today
there are many more opportunities for
women than they were during my
grandmother's time
because of changes in policy changes in
law all of which are very important
but what matters even more is our
attitude
our mindset what we believe and what we
value about gender
what if in raising children we focus on
ability instead of gender what if in
raising children we focus on interest
instead of gender i know a family who
have a son and a daughter both of whom
are brilliant at school who are
wonderful lovely children
when the boy is hungry the parents say
to the girl go and cook indomie noodles
for your brother
now the girl doesn't particularly like
to cook in dummy noodles
but she's a girl and so she has to now
what if the parents
from the beginning taught both the boy
and the girl
to cook into me cooking by the way is a
very useful skill for a boy to have
i've never i've never thought it made
sense to leave such a crucial thing
the ability to nourish oneself
in the hands of others
[Applause]
[Music]
i know i know a woman who has the same
degree and the same job as her husband
when they get back from work
she does most of the housework which i
think is true for many marriages
but what struck me about them was that
whenever her husband changed the baby's
diaper
she said thank you to him
now what if she saw this as perfectly
normal and natural that he should in
fact
care for his child
i'm trying to unlearn many of the
lessons of gender that i
internalized when i was growing up but i
sometimes feel very still feel very
vulnerable in the face of gender
expectations
the first time i taught a writing class
in graduate school
i was worried i wasn't worried about the
material i would teach because i was
well prepared and i was going to teach
what i enjoyed
teaching instead i was worried about
what to wear
i wanted to be taken seriously i knew
that because i was female i would
automatically have to
prove my worth and i was worried that if
i looked too feminine i would not be
taken seriously
i really wanted to wear my shiny lip
gloss and my girly skirt
but i decided not to instead i wore a
very serious very manly and very ugly
suit because the sad truth is that when
it comes to appearance we start off with
men as the standard as the norm
if a man is getting ready for a business
meeting he doesn't worry about looking
too masculine
and therefore not being taken for
granted if a woman
is getting ready for a business meeting
she has to worry about looking too
feminine
and what it says and whether or not she
will be taken for granted whether or not
she will be taken seriously
i wish i had not won that ugly suit that
day
i've actually banished it from my closet
by the way
had i then the confidence that i have
now
to be myself my students would have
benefited even more from my teaching
because i would have been more
comfortable and more fully and more
truly myself
i have chosen to no longer be apologetic
for my femaleness and for my femininity
[Applause]
and i want to be respected in all of my
femaleness because i deserve to be
gender is not an easy conversation to
have
for both men and women to bring up
gender is sometimes to encounter an
almost immediate
resistance i can imagine some people
here actually thinking
women to do safe
some of the men here might be thinking
okay all of this is interesting but i
don't think like that and that is part
of the problem
that many men do not actively think
about gender or notice gender
is part of the problem of gender that
many men say like my friend louie
that everything is fine now and that
many men do nothing
to change it if you are a man and you
walk into a restaurant with a woman and
the waiter greets only you
does it occur to you to ask the waiter
why haven't you greeted her
because gender can be
actually women rapper was part of the
longer version of this talk
so because gender can be an it can be
very uncomfortable conversation to have
they're very easy ways to close it to
close the conversation
so some people will bring up
evolutionary biology
and apes how you know female apes bow
down to male apes
and that sort of thing but the point is
we're not apes
[Applause]
you know
apes also live on trees and have
earthworms
for breakfast and we don't
some people will say well poor men also
have a hard time
and this is true but that is not what
this is
but this is not what this conversation
is about
gender and class are different forms of
oppression
i actually learned quite a bit about
systems of oppression and how they can
be blind to one another
by talking to black men i was once
talking to
a black man about gender and he said to
me why do you have to say
my experience as a woman why can't it be
your experience as a human being
now this was the same man who would
often talk about his experience as a
black man
gender matters men and women experience
the world differently
gender colors the way we experience the
world but we can change that
some people will say oh but women have
the real power bottom power and for non
nigerians bottom power is an expression
which
i suppose means something like a woman
who uses her sexuality to get
favors from men but bottom power is not
power at all
bottom power means that a woman simply
has a good route to tap
into from time to time somebody else's
power
and then of course we have to wonder
what happens when that somebody else is
in a bad mood
or sick or impotent
so some people will say that a woman
being
subordinate to a man is our culture
but culture is constantly changing i
have beautiful twin
nieces who are 15 and live in lagos if
they had been born 100 years ago
they would have been taken away and
killed because it was our culture it was
able culture to kill twins
so what is the point of culture i mean
there's the decorative
the dancing the but also culture really
is about preservation and continuity of
the people
in my family i am the child who is most
interested
in the story of who we are in our
traditions and the knowledge of
ancestral lands
my brothers are not as interested as i
am but i cannot participate
i cannot go to mundane meetings i cannot
have a say
because i am female culture does not
make people
people make culture so if it is in fact
true
so so if it is in fact true that the
full humanity of women is not our
culture
then we must make it our culture
i think i think very often of my dear
friend oklahoma maduro
may he and all the others who passed
away and that's a solicitor crash
continue to rest in peace
he will always be remembered by those of
us who loved him
and he was right that day many years ago
when he called me a feminist
i am a feminist and when i looked up the
word in the dictionary that day this is
what it said
feminist a person who believes in the
social political
and economic equality of the sexes
my great-grandmother from the stories
i've heard was a feminist
she ran away from the house of the man
she did not want to marry
and ended up marrying the man of her
choice she refused she protested she
spoke up
whenever she felt she was being deprived
of access
of land that sort of thing my great
grandmother did not know that word
feminist
but it doesn't mean that she wasn't one
more of us should reclaim that word
my own definition of feminist is
a feminist is a man or a woman who says
yes there's a problem with gender as it
is today
and we must fix it we must do better
the best feminist i know is my brother
kenny
he's also a kind good looking lovely man
and he's very masculine thank you
you